[Music]
yeah it's not that easy
what's up my name is remy adeleke i
spent 13 years in the military with the
majority of that time spent in special
operations as a navy seal
and uh today i'm going to be breaking
down some iconic navy seal
movies and tv shows
yeah i've never seen any devices like
that
[Music]
we're called seals uh partner seal is
actually acronym c
air land a lot of people don't know that
so it's it's typical for us to
uh to work in the water i've jumped out
of a plane into the water before
i've jumped out of a helicopter into the
water before and they've seen it jumping
not only they're jumping out but they're
pushing vehicles uh underwater vehicles
uh into the water now those type of
vehicles i've never seen in my life
there are there are there are vehicles
that we do use called sdvs it stands for
steel delivery vehicles
there are times when if somebody has a
a unique specialization but they're not
a seal
they will go on a mission um uh and they
will be embedded within
within a sealed platoon however um
they're not gonna be at the front of the
train they're not gonna be the first one
in a door
that's for sure and they're gonna be
somewhere somewhere in the middle
somewhere protected
somewhere where they can't they can't
hurt the uh the other guys within
within the platoon the rock inspired me
that was the first time i was exposed to
navy seals i had never heard of navy
seals before
and and i went to go watch the film and
when i saw these guys
that really intrigued me and then when
we got to the scene where
they actually sacrificed themselves to
save other people
that's what really kind of stuck out to
me this this idea that these
these men are are so close-knit they're
skilled
um they're great at what they do and
and they're willing to put their lives
on the line for other people
i've worked with michael bay on some
other films so got to be careful
i would say i would give it a 8.5 as far
as uh
accuracy you know
it's supposed to be boats on heads but
they have they're holding it with their
hands
we've never done that there's an
instructor in the boat
nah that's not gonna happen the boat is
heavy as it is
the bell yep uh bell that's definitely
real
um i know a lot of guys are rang that
bell
now now these things i'm assuming that
these are buoys
um we've never we never did that at all
we never pushed buoys through uh looks
like a
a berm obstacle course so i don't know
what that is and here we have the buoy
rolling over people
um that that's not happening i mean
that's more of a liability
[Music]
now this type of surf torture i have
never seen it
i don't know what kind of push-up that
is
it's a mental exercise at least for me
it was you're laying in
in this freezing cold water um you don't
know how long you're gonna be in the
water
and and that's where they get a lot of
guys who quit that's where you do get a
lot of quitters um
me there's there were multiple times
during during hell week and various
evolutions where where during surf
torture
i was either near hypothermia or
hypothermic as a matter of fact during
one turf torture and hell week my core
temperature dropped down to 88.7 degrees
so
and what happened after that was the
instructors took me to bud's medical
uh uh re went through a rewarming drill
i think it took about an hour or two to
reward me and then uh as soon as i was
back to a normal core temperature
they i went right back into hell week
and when the instructors asked me they
said hey you want to quit it you want to
go back in that cold water and uh
i said i'll go back in the cold water so
the instructors are trying to put you in
a situation where you have to
you have to work together as a team and
push through the discomfort um
there's cases where if you're not
running in sync the boat will
will bob and bounce on a person's head
and that just causes more pain there's
actually been
been guys who have had serious neck
injuries and and fractured their necks
because
because of the bouncing or because
somebody within the boat was ducking
boat which means
they were they were they had their their
head down while other people were
carrying the weight so it's it's a
pretty serious evolution
an instructor in the boat i would have
to give it a
about a four
six times three
hurry up hurry up what we're seeing here
is
a swim it's called it's called wetsuit
appreciation swim
and uh essentially they're making you
swim in freezing cold water for a long
period of time without a wetsuit and
it's miserable it's horrible
yeah this guy he's a shallow water but
not shadow
yeah shallow water blackout you know he
blacked out from being on the water
the majority of it is footage from a
discovery channel uh documentary called
buds234
and interestingly i i watched that
documentary uh in order to prepare for
buds because uh
you know coming from coming from the
bronx and and uh
i i didn't have a lot of exposure to
navy seals or or how to prepare for seal
training
it's about that when i joined a navy i
couldn't swim
[Music]
two minutes you don't make it you do it
again you've even tested this hard ever
in your life
never buds is six months broken up in
three phases
first phase which is where they really
weed out the majority of the class
then their second phase which is
diaphase that's when when you're
they're beginning to really teach you uh
different elements of of being a seal
and then third phases weapons tactics
land warfare and demolitions if a person
makes it through six months of buds then
next step is sqt seal qualification
training that's where you
really get into the weeds of what it
means to be a navy seal and
and to do the job that we do and then
from there you go on to your seal team
on nutrition rate for sale training
fluctuates between 75 and 90 percent
uh the class that i graduated with
started out with 270
uh and uh we only graduated 29 guys
uh i i have to give it a 10. because
it's the real deal you don't get no
realer than that
all right listen to me listen hey listen
up when you go outside that gate you go
left you understand yes the right is bad
guys you're going left you're taking the
back way to the end
you got it i got it this guy who's
driving
and he seems disoriented and he's not
paying attention it's because most
likely he's not a seal
if he was a seal he wouldn't be as
confused on the roof
what was going on was the guys were
bounding um and when when a union is
bounding
away from a contact um it's always
important for
for for for one or two or three however
many guys to be
shooting and the others part of that
team moving you know we call that
shoot move or cover move so in the clip
you know um
john's character said cover and move and
and that's something
we always do when we're bounding from a
contact those are all weapons that
um that uh not only you know i've
carried but i've seen other guys uh
in my platoon and my teams carry when we
go out the door on operations
this movie 13 hours is based off of uh
from an actual
event that happened and benghazi the
embassy was attacked
and overrun the guys who were were
defending
for the most part they were all all guys
with special operations backgrounds
um a few of them were navy seals
actually one of them the guy who got who
got killed um
ty ty woods was my bud's instructor um
he put me through seal training
personally i would i would give it a 9.5
so they have fast roping i fast roll
before fat
rope it's a it's an easy way to insert
into a situation
senior you're clear
this guy right here he's an intelligence
guy he's a seal but he's also an
intelligence guy
um we call it human which is human
intelligence and that's what i did in
the seal teams
not only are they covering down on doors
as as one guy's as the point man is
moving forward but they're covering down
on windows
so everything is a threat when you're in
operation especially you know in a uh
on a ship like this or a uh or a house
you know closets open doors um
windows um hidden spaces
and one guy says clear um clear is just
that's something we say when the room is
clear that doesn't mean that nobody's in
the room that means that the
the the room is clear
the style bolts that you saw on the clip
um they're really high speed
um they're operated by uh by a special
operations unit called swick
swig stands for special warfare combat
uh craft crewmen
along the rivers and any operation along
the water they help insert seals and
extract seals
from targets they used real navy seals
and real swick operators as the main
actors
so i would give it a 9.5 the point five
that's that's missing is the fact that
you know
in hollywood you gotta you gotta uh
you gotta spice up a little bit to have
a storyline i get that as a writer so
jesus damn it doesn't look good
we always check each other's gear my
platoon chief had the same check check
and recheck
this is a halo standard halo jumping out
oh [ __ ] so what's going on here this guy
has a malfunction
um
yeah he's his this reserve
opens pretty late uh
probably because he cut away late
yeah it's not that easy if you have a
malfunction
and uh you've tried to fix it and uh uh
it didn't work
you got to cut away and essentially what
it is you look down you look down at
that at that red tab and
you you pull that cut away first and
then you look down at your reserve and
you pull that away second in that order
um there have been people who've died
not just in the military but in civilian
jumping
because they had a malfunction and they
made it worse by opening their reserve
parachute before cutting away
and the reserve parachute now gets
tangled in their main parachute and
this is just i mean it's there's nothing
you can do after that i have to give it
this
i'd have to give it a five man to give
it a five
echo zero two moving to deck three
first and foremost operating at night
every this is
this is a a d a it's a direct action
going after a specific target i've done
a lot of these
and 99 of them have been at night
i think i heard three shots initially
and then he shot him again while i was
on the ground and said well that's
excessive
um we do that for a reason because you
know it's not like in the movies
the movies you shoot a guy one time he
falls in reality you know you should
have got
six seven eight times he can still fight
so
see they're really silent it's just hand
squeezes and
there's no verbal communication
i mean it was a mirror image of a lot of
the operations i've been on
as far as like the movements and the
tactics and sneaking
those through that you see we can see
them because of the type of camera that
was used but
we use ir lasers on our weapons um
typically in some movies you'll see the
red lasers or green lasers on guns
that's super unrealistic
we use hand signals um or you know or we
use our weapons
as a way to communicate with each other
um so that we can stay stealth and
and stay completely silent and not not
tip off off the enemy
all clear when it came across the women
the first thing that they did
um was they searched them um and they
were searching them for a suicide vest
the enemy will put suicide vests on on
women uh
and children i remember there was a guy
we were tracking for a long period of
time and
won't mention a country we were in where
he would recruit you know kids 9
8 7 11 12 13
and put suicide vs on them uh rating for
this one
this scene the specific scene because of
the way they moved to tactically i would
give it a 9.5 just like that
hear what you guys have to say about it
that's all speak freely
my opinion sir we caught our losses
this isn't our war it's one of my
favorite navy seal movies i'll say that
i'll say that first and foremost it was
directed by a phenomenal director by the
name of antoine fuqua
it really shows the the interaction
between
uh between seals but not just not just
seals but you know the leadership of the
seal platoon
and and and and the other guys the sled
dogs so to speak
we have a saying again leadership at
every level and so we
all are able to give our input i've been
in situations with with um
with my oic oh i see the officer in
charge of the platoon
and and where he he wants everybody's
input he wants to hear hey how should we
take down
how should we take down this target what
should when it's not like other military
units where you just had you have one
guy in charge and
and you know he says go storm that
mountain and everybody just mindlessly
goes and storms that mountain
and interestingly a lot of people don't
know this but the requirements
academically to get in seal training
are really really high and a lot of guys
who do show up to seal training
buds um they have bachelor's degrees a
lot of them have master's degrees
there were guys who were established i
mean there were guys who were
accountants
and lawyers uh or big
businessmen and one day they woke up and
said you know what this is boring i want
to be a navy seal
yeah you know that scene i would i
wouldn't get a 9.5
it's hard for me to give anything a 10
but yeah for that scene absolutely a 9.5
not only these guys covering and moving
but it had proper
360 security which allowed that one seal
to see that suicide bomber
as soon as they took contact they
immediately started firing back
and that's something that we always do
um we you know suppress the threat
and then yeah again we had 360 security
so um
the contact was in the front and you
know again seals are not mindless robots
so
so everybody did just start shooting at
the contact in the front if somebody
gets injured
in the field you know first and foremost
if they could take care of themselves
they take care of themselves in the
middle of the battle
um and then once somebody can get to
them then that person you know
goes and gets them and tends to them in
the navy we don't call medics medics we
call him corman once that corpsman can
get to him after the threat has been
been uh suppressed at that point then
they'll go 10 to him
level 6 say again your last six to base
i say again
fallen eagle somebody gets killed in
operation you know you
you win the fight and and after you win
the fight you know you uh
you uh you know you you know you help
you know transport
uh transport them back to base and give
them a proper ceremony
long till we can get them out of there
we give that that scene uh specifically
a 9.5
i need sights on targets i need three
targets green
passing comms to the to the snipers who
are going to take the target so they
so they're aware of what's going on
again going back to communication
communications key
execute
he could have been a commander commander
is actually a rink um
but for the sake of just just just
explaining this point you know we
we had a commander who was definitely a
navy seal
and uh and he is he's he's given
commands but he's also
given the guys you know giving guys
freedom to do their job he's not
he's not a uh he's not micromanaging
them and so throughout that scene there
was a lot of great communication and
that's
9.5 and 9.5 is like a 10. i
and i i have to say 9.5 because you know
you know hollywood has to spice things
up and
dramatize things so i get that so but
you know for me i would say that was a
9.5